good morning believe nation today's
message is turn your struggles into
triumphs over to you Taylor Swift
challenge of this year actually was
convincing members of my own team that
this was a good call I'd get kind of
called in front of a group of people who
have known me and worked with me for
years who would sit down and say are you
sure you want to call the album 1989 we
think it's a weird title are you sure
that you want to put an album cover out
that has less than half of your face on
it are you positive that you want to you
want to take a seanrid
that cemented yourself in and completely
switch to a new one that you are a
newcomer to and answering all those
questions with yes I'm sure that was I
think something that really frustrated
me at the time like guys don't you
understand
I promise this is this is what I'm dying
to do the biggest kind of struggle
turned into the biggest triumph I think
it's people and especially entrepreneurs
we crave creativity we crave newness we
hate doing the same thing repeatedly
over and over and over and over again
the more you are asked you the same
thing again the client wants the exact
same work the more you get bored with it
the more you want to branch out the more
you want to try something new and let
your creative feathers fly and so it's
natural to want to break out and try new
things and then it's natural for there
to be fears and for there to be people
who don't you people just say are you
sure you want to do that that's not
really the smartest thing to do you
haven't had any experience there maybe
you shouldn't go that way and it's
normal for you to doubt yourself too
which is the even scarier part that's
the thing that's really holding you back
is you wonder I don't know if I can do
this and so because you're so afraid you
don't try but what's the alternative the
alternative is never doing anything new
the alternate is never reaching out the
alternative is never exploring your
creativity alternative is having a
boring life and that's what most people
do 90% of America would
up and drive to a job that they hate and
that shouldn't be you I would much
rather try something and fail then not
know if it would work then live the rest
of my life with regret saying I wish I
just tried that thing and so you need to
branch out if you feel yourself being
pulled in a certain direction explored
in the low-risk way it doesn't mean you
have to burn all your bridges and go all
in and sell the house and quit your job
and put everything on the line on that
but do something to take some kind of
action
get some momentum building in your favor
if you are pulled in a direction even it
doesn't make any sense
you owe it to yourself to try because
the alternative is a life an entire life
of mediocrity and the upside is you
found something that becomes your goal
that that's where the magic is that's
what the impact is that's what the value
is and the funny thing about it is it
doesn't always work out like in Taylor
Swift's example it worked out great she
took this risk and it worked out and she
can look back on it and say I turned
that struggle into my Trump but it
doesn't always work out like you may
fall on your face it may not work for
you
you may try and fail and try again and
struggle and still fail but what's the
answer then to go back to that job that
you hate to go back to that life that is
safe but doesn't make any sense for you
to be the rest of your life unhappy
because you're not willing to get back
up to the table and take another hand
that's how most people live I tried one
thing it didn't work out and so this
isn't meant for me and and so gonna have
this crappy job the rest of my life
don't expect it to work out on the first
time you have to explore explore explore
and the things that make you come alive
until you find a way to provide value to
people so that you can make it don't
live the rest of your life regretting
what could have happened if you took
just one more chance on yourself so the
question today today is I'm curious when
was the last time you turned one of your
struggles into a triumph leave it in the
comments I'll join in the discussion
thank you guys so much for watching have
an amazing day continue to believe and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events presser
more this prey so give me go